dr. Sachin man dead car is a man on a
mission and he's crossing the city of
Pune to make a rare house call he's here
to treat Rajiv kid car who suffers from
a chronic skin condition called
psoriasis and the Rajiv his eager for
doctor Sachin to ease his suffering he's
more than a little unsettled because he
knows the cure in this doctors bag is
one that's certain to get under his skin
leeches every year millions of Indians
choose not to visit their country's
modern medical clinics instead they seek
traditional healers like dr. Sachin who
use leeches as part of an ancient system
of medicine called Ayurveda it's
holistic approach to treating illness
includes dietary changes curative oils
massages and relaxation therapies and
leeches for dr. Sachin the results speak
for themselves
show us positive results but even here
leeches are often taboo if I see a leech
I can't stand it I won't even go near it
why would anyone voluntarily allow
himself to become a meal for a blood
sucking leech Rajiv is convinced this
leech will provide relief for his
psoriasis he's tried Western medicine
and it hasn't worked in certain cases
like Rajiv psoriasis dr. Sachin and his
wife dr. kirtan and dead car believe a
patient's ailment stem from toxins or
impurities in the blood basically
desired with the concept not in modern
science
Ayurveda insists that leeches naturally
remove toxic blood from the body we just
applied the leech due to the local part
of body which is affected to take out
the blood impurities
the metate is quite natural and zero
percent of hommies dead but not
necessarily for the leech blood
impurities are said to be as dangerous
to these parasites as they are to the
patient so Ayurvedic doctors douse their
leeches in turmeric powder to get them
to expel the toxic blood we just make
the leeches to vomit because she cannot
digest impure blood dr. Sachin is
optimistic that people's faith in
leeches will continue to hang on by
embracing this taboo treatment patients
keep an ancient cure alive and well